[Music]
we gotta go
i'm gonna have to break a window to get
inside that thing
oh nobody's afraid of heights
[Music]
don't move
[Music]
[Music]
how are you kids hmm
amazing grown it's shocking they're both
in college can you believe that
and mark
it's over
oh
oh i'm sorry to hear that
it's okay
i'm back to me
and my work you know it's
that's great it's good it is i'm alone
at last exciting times
yeah i'm living the alan grant life it's
just gonna be lonely so free
ali
you didn't come out all this way just to
catch up now did you
[Music]
[Applause]
you still get nightmares
[Applause]
all the time
no one said saving the planet was going
to be easy
but you can't stay in the past
what matters what is that is what we do
now run
on the verge of extinction
humans and dinosaurs can't co-exist
[Music]
classification
the doomsday clock might be out of time
come back
i always come back
we're on the verge of extinction
let's all try to stay positive nobody
said saving the planet would be easy is
that a dinosaur on your shoulder
here i am with blue she's pretty
extraordinary
[Music]
owen's relationship with blue is one
that you invest in through the course of
the franchise blue eyes on me
that's good
you finally did it man in the first
movie owen is coming to terms with what
he's created with blue
your boyfriend's a badass
in jurassic world she lost all of her
sisters
and in fallen kingdom she's been
displaced from her home
[Music]
so in the case of dominion blue now has
a baby and is becoming a parent you look
just like blue is she your mother owen
is going through a similar journey he
has obligations now he's got something
beyond himself to think about
hazy don't move hey girl
staying out of trouble we get to see
that not only are these parents dinosaur
and human alike recognizing they have
certain responsibilities
whoa
but these two characters have been
living lives that mirror each other
[Music]
owen is trying to protect beta who's in
danger
blue and owen they've both been through
a lot i promise you that i am going to
get her back
you take off on a new adventure with
these characters you've grown to love
run
it's really epic
you made a promise
to a dinosaur yeah what
jurassic world dominion
in cinemas june 10.
in jurassic world dominion
the park is gone
and dinosaurs are everywhere
owen claire and maisie are living off
the grid
had a baby that's impossible
girl
you look just like your mother
i promise i am gonna get her back
jurassic world dominion gave us the
opportunity to take the franchise to new
and different places
i have to fix a terrible mistake that
i've made
you coming or what
i have to warn you everyone's so excited
to have you you guys are absolute
legends around here our storylines
intersect we get to reacquaint with old
friends and get to know new friends
it feels like this is the closing of the
chapter
you're willing to risk your life for
people you've never met
you want to ask questions or you want to
rise
i thought it was a fantastic idea to
bring these two worlds together
i made a promise we would bring it home
you made a promise
to a dinosaur yeah why
jurassic world dominion is the
culmination of the franchise
we give you something that you want but
do not expect
that can't be right i've never seen
action like this ever
most scary and awesome dinosaurs you've
ever seen
what is that
[Music]
blue had a baby that's impossible
hey girl
you look just like your mother
[Music]
genetic power has now been unleashed
we made a terrible mistake
the doomsday clock might be about out of
time
if our world's gonna survive what
matters is what we do now
i can use your expertise
you comment or what
a baby raptor i made a promise we would
bring her home
you made a promise
to a dinosaur yeah what
[Music]
everybody hold on to somebody
that can't be right
what is that biggest carnivore the world
has ever seen
run
see not so bad
[Music]
you